on verra
ce petit garçon à 11 ans il s'appelle
emmanuel curtil bientôt il sera votre
nouveau gavroche on vient de tourner à
trente cinquième version des misérables
adapté par alain decaux réalisé par
robert hossein
mais derrière le matelas est tombée
toute la paille est sorti ce jour là on
se battait sur les barricades dans le
grand studio de la ssp abri sûrement cet
immense décor a été conçu par françois
de la motte le directeur de photographie
c'était de montrichard
ce qui serait bien regarde c'est qu'il
donne à ses couleurs grenat dans l'autre
tous est organisée rodez view flore dans
la défense charles ix qui y voit là un
vaisseau chargé boutique même nombreux
mais me direz vous les recevez vous
tirez le même principe que je vais vous
tirez vous que l'artiste voit une espèce
de police qui nous fait est que les vols
soit vous êtes sans les voir aller doit
pas y aller
robert hossein se livre avec
enthousiasme sa mise en scène
il semble plonger dans les gravures des
éditions populaire de victor hugo
c'est un sujet qu'on ne peut pas prêter
100 x 100 fougue sans lyrisme il est
impossible de prendre le monde comme ça
c'est pas possible il faut vraiment
soulever le gars le golfe et l'emmener à
sa sphère même sauvé non là c'était
intéressant bien que tous les passants
c'est que je suis le dernier ce côté
disparaît avec le premier en prenant le
mmm et [ __ ] de lui on recommence
mais il est tombé par terre c'est la
faute à voltaire le nez dans le ruisseau
c'est la faute à rousseau parfait
voici donc les misérables avec gavroche
et marius et causait des thénardier des
misérables avec les barricades et les
égouts et waterloo et jean valjean jean
valjean roues et il est bien il arrive
le voici c'est lino ventura il apporte
sa densité est aussi l'affection dont le
public l'entourent à un personnage qui
appartient à notre sensibilité
collective un héros qu'on n'a pas le
droit de maltraiter
il y as javert aussi bien sur le
policier dont victor hugo dit qu'il a un
regard à vous retourner les poches
un regard qui ne pénètre pas mais qui
fouillent c'est michel bouquet ce face à
face
nous allons découvrir dans quelques
semaines chesnot des robots